is there a world where there's a
descendants for ya
I do think there's a world where where
that happens I don't know anything for
sure okay I can't but I definitely don't
think that that's like an impossibility
dove Cameron weighing in on a possible
descendants for exclusively to et it's
funny because I talked to was it you
were Sophia and you guys said
descendants three was like the end of
that chapter so what what a descendents
for look like and of course we lost
Cameron and yeah how would that all in
your mind play out I mean those are my
questions to I think like as somebody
who I was always very involved in the
franchise like I have always felt like a
part of the conversation when it came to
descendants especially I felt like they
you know gave me a lot of room to be
like do you want to do this do you not
want to do this different things like
that I want to be really clear there's
actually a rumor that I was a part of
the script writing for descendants three
and I did not write a single thing for
descent and three there's like this
rumor that I cuz I said that there I was
I got to know that like a previous plot
that they were playing with him and then
I got to hear about what the new plot
was four to seven three and somehow that
got twisted and people were like she
wrote it that's not fair but I had
nothing to do with the writing I
absolutely swear but I did I did always
feel very involved and so I do feel it
sort of like in those conversations I
you know I don't I don't I don't love
the idea of doing it without Cameron um
I don't know what the plot would be I
don't know what it would look like but I
also love the franchise and I love Kenny
and I love Disney and I love the cast
and I loved that time in my life and
who's to say if that was a time in my
life or if that's something that that
maybe continues on in a different
incarnation I don't know sure yeah I
think you're gonna make a lot of fans
very happy with that why I don't know
yeah right there's nothing that I can
say for sure but I definitely I
definitely can say that it is not out of
the question yeah though we lost Cameron
Boyce earlier this year it seems a new
chapter of descendants could it happen
people's lives are in danger
but dove is also focused on her music
she's got a new song out called
so good relatable subject I mean I do
love the lyric maybe I just woke up on
the right side of my empty bed or I'm
not sad when I'm watching him leave
right you know because I I've said very
publicly I do not like a breakup song
it's a song about a girl who is turning
a page and I've definitely been there
[Music]
what does this mean for acting like are
you a hundred percent focused on singing
and music right now no I actually I just
got it I actually just got a phone call
two nights ago that my next movie is
moving forward is it wicked it's not
working
that'd be amazing no I can't I can't say
too much about it right now but I'm
really happy about it because I've
mostly been doing I like my my dream is
that I constantly switch back and forth
between like movies TV music and stage
and if I ever do something repetitively
for too long I get like really itchy
okay um so I'm like I'm really ready for
this new era of like film and music
those two things for me go together yeah
really well yeah will it be in the
Disney family or something a little
different you know there are two and one
is not really what one is more in the
Disney family than the other but it's
not a Disney Channel venture okay Disney
Plus I can't say okay I can't say but I
tried I'm sorry I was like it's a but
the other one is no it's it's very far
from anything and it isn't family yeah
it's it kind of nice to sort of explore
like a more mature path you know it's so
funny it's this this like last couple
months has been so focused on like me
leaving Disney and graduating and what's
gonna happen and like kind of like a
subtext of like what am I gonna lose my
mind and I just feel nothing about that
like I feel it was such a wonderful time
in my life when I was on Disney and it's
been such an easy transition and Disney
really has been so like nurturing I've I
never felt that kind of like I was in a
pressure box like I was never like get
me out and so when it ended it was much
more like wow I never realized how much
it's keep saying this and I look so I
keep looking for a better way to say it
but it's like when you leave your
parents house to go to college it's like
I didn't realize how much of me and what
I was doing and putting out there was
affected by where I was because it just
felt so natural and normal and I didn't
really think about it yeah
and now I'm I feel really like naturally
stepping into this new era for myself
and I also feel really like supported by
the people around me it's very much like
no one's like what are you doing like
stop you know getting tattoos and stop
swearing in your songs it's very like
it's it just seems like a natural
transition and so I I don't really feel
a pressure to change that or like I'm
like looking for more mature roles or
substance or like anything like that I
just feel like it's not really happening
sure yeah so it just feels it feels good
but it felt good that too you know it
yeah I feel at peace
is there a dream role for you that you
would love to play aside from wicked
well gelinda was always my dream growing
up and so I'm very pleased that it
hasn't happened yet because I'm like I
feel like I'm like at the right age
that's gonna happen soon cuz I talked to
Kristen Chenoweth and she really wants
you and ariana grande together in that
movie yeah how you and Ari talked about
it yes I mean yeah I mean like you know
I think that it's much less official
than it sounds like I think that like I
mean it's not official at all but I just
mean like I think that we're like if Ari
and I have talked about it it's just
more like on like a girlish but you
would like to do it yeah we're friends
so it's like it's more like Oh wouldn't
that be so cool like did you see Kristin
posted you know like it's that kind of
thing it's not like yeah meet your one
when's that you know it's nothing like
that
and I have two out so I don't have
anything to do with the movie at all and
I just feel very lucky to be part of the
conversation and Kristin's like my dream
so yeah that's right
she's been vouching for you for a very
long time I can't it's unbelievably
surreal to me she's she's she was my
icon since I was tiny
[Music]